it's over anakin i have the high ground
you underestimate my power
the force is very strong over at disney
which last week announced a galactic
federation's worth of star wars content
coming to our big and small screens
over the next few years but don't you
worry because we're gonna bite-size this
bantha down for you
by focusing on three different titles
right now on the ketchup
disney's investor day was a cornucopia
of content this year with over 50 new
series
and movies announced when it was star
wars turn at the mic lucasfilms as
kathleen kennedy confirmed
two feature films and 10 new disney plus
shows rolling out over the next several
years
first up hayden christensen is
re-entering the star wars universe for
the upcoming obi-wan series
starring ewan mcgregor can you tell i'm
excited
set 10 years after revenge of the sith
and a decade before a new hope the show
will focus on ben kenobi's last years on
tatooine and i for one can't wait to see
how obi goes from looking like
you into alec guinness in 20 years but
maybe he forgot to wear his two
sunscreens
get it i felt a great disturbance in the
force kennedy teased that the show would
feature a confrontation between the jedi
master and his former paduan after the
two
last faced off on mustafar a fight which
costs obi-wan his faith
and anakin an arm and two legs kennedy
actually referred to the showdown as
quote the rematch of
the century no disrespect but seems kind
of like an inaccurate assessment of
these guys's history considering the
next time vader and obi-wan meet again
in a new hope
one of them gets sliced in half by a
lightsaber last time we checked it's
hard to top murder in the epic rematch
category but who knows
the long-awaited series which was
allegedly scrapped back in january and
put on hold while the concept was
retooled still has a number of question
marks ranging from release date to the
number of episodes
but low-key this kind of gives me hope
that maybe the lazy maguire series will
come back to life
but anyway our number one question is
will james earl jones
make a vocal cameo now that anakin has
his helmet on
as far as what we do know the show will
start filming in march of 2021
and at the helm is deborah chow now chow
recently directed the mandalorian season
one penultimate episode
so we know she's good at getting great
helmet-based performances
this is the way while the obi-wan series
will be sandwiched between the events of
the prequels and the original trilogy
the upcoming rogue squadron film will be
giving us our
most futuristic glimpse into the star
wars universe yet
and no we're not just talking about the
release date which right now is slated
for a very distant sound in christmas
2023.
first formed by luke skywalker the rogue
squadron has already been the subject of
games and novelizations over the years
but director patty jenkins stated that
her movie will be an
entirely original story set in a future
era introducing audiences to a new
generation of pilots
as the first female director of a star
wars movie jenkins is
already pushing the franchise in a new
direction away from the skywalker saga
and in a twitter video released shortly
after the disney announcement she said
that she was inspired by her father's
death in the air force to make the
greatest fighter pilot movie of all time
so expect more top gun than rogue one
that's one hell of a pilot before
rosario dawson's non-animated debut in
the season of the mandalorian fans were
rightly demanding to know
where the dank ferrick was ahsoka tano
and now we know
the beloved character from the clone
wars and rebels cartoon series will be
getting her own
live-action spin-off but first some
backstory having been trained by none
other than anakin
ahsoka never became a full jedi instead
defecting to help the resistance
she later teamed up with a young jedi
named ezra bridger after he reached
through time in space and saved her from
darth vader but
lost contact after he disappeared on a
ship set to hyperspace
while fighting grand admiral thrawn now
in the mandalorian ahsoka is still
looking for thrawn so we can assume that
the show will continue her quest
to find ezra and suss out the thrawn
which could also tie in with another
upcoming star wars series rangers of the
new republic
but we'll have to break down rangers and
the other new series
lando and or the bad batch the acolyte
another day not to mention the new
untitled taika watisi star wars film and
disney clearly wasn't done with the news
because they just announced
another spin-off series the book of boba
fett coming to disney plus in 2021
right now little is known about the
series but stay tuned for more on that
because we'll be breaking down what the
finale of mandalorian season 2
means for the future of star wars next
time
there are too many of them what are we
going to do
all right friends it's time for us to
first throw it over to you now is this
enough star wars content to make your
little heart sing
are you lowkey upset that jar jar binks
doesn't have his own spin-off yet
please let us know all your thoughts and
feelings in the comments section and of
course if you want more disney investor
news head on over to rottentomatoes.com
and if you don't want to miss out on any
future episodes of this show be sure to
hit that subscribe button and
notification bell and as always
can't thank you enough for watching the
ketchup my name is as perez and may the
force be with you
[Music]
bye
[Music]
you